so
[Music]
uh what version is this
okay
um
when do i
enter
in terms of yin and yang theory
when there's a yin space okay
so
there's a couple things you can see
at some point
i'm going to enter
he could do that with a pull go ahead
but now i have a problem because at some
point i'm going to turn
and when do i turn
he pushes him when he's pushing okay
that he needs yarn for me again
also there's a problem with the pull
because it's
representative of social violence not a
social violence because there's no
territoriality no spinal displacement
and so it is a what if
this is not kihon wasn't
okay
so the idea that he's just staying there
and i go around is equally wrong because
he has no
spinal displacement okay
so in other words if he gives me the
spinal displacement
i can't enter
because that's young young
do you understand that
okay
so what there is initially is this faith
to his young to his
spinal displacement
i take it around
and then he hits the ground
to do that
you can't go around him
and try to get his elbow and his wrist
in different planes
because the elbow keeps going
unless you get turns for you
or
you yawn the elbow
it's just big man i told
little by little
i'm not pushing down
he's falling and i'm staying in the
check-in position
it's staying even with him
so
it looks like i'm
entering against him it's just i don't
have the gap on the projection
so as soon as he comes off me boom i'm
injured already
i'm not throwing him
and then
you have to reconcile yin and yang
okay
more on yin and yang let's ask a
question at
this point
clearly the elbow handle
takes over
clearly the elbow hand at that point is
young
which means up to that point it had to
have been one yeah it had to have been
yet so i'm not going like this
it's shut
the elbow
the call q is in this hand
[Music]
which means it went to you
which is why the other hand kicks up
beyond
so
don't shut this elbow down
violation
you go on the other way
then
it's just in place
not doing anything
just in place
then
down there it is
again it looks like i hit him but if
your yin and yang are off
it's just
big man aikido which is not aikido it's
just you overpowering something
when you do a keyhole waza
you want to do the body mechanics
of that keep on lesson
once you have internal skills
you don't need the body mechanics so
eventually you want to transcend the
body mechanics find the same technique
with different body mechanics that are
energetic okay so for example
here i take his wrist and elbow in a
different plane do you see that but from
here you can still find that same center
you see that i'm not passing his elbow
you see so i'm over here but it's still
in the center as i'm going do you
understand that
when we do this move
it's mechanically
unsound to use your outer deltoid
you make this big circle
it looks like it works it doesn't work
small muscle group
it also exposes the side of your body
right here
okay
so
this time is not making that circle that
you think it's making
he's got a sword
are you going to lift the sword up
that's what you're doing
so the arm is straight
my arm is straight
as i move to the outside
i'm on the outside of his hand
going to show me
very similar do you see that
not like this
it's not like this
that is the angle of the arm
the shape of the hand is also not
arbitrary
you must have this shape
not this shape
this shape
the angle of the wrist is also not
arbitrary
and the rotation of the wrist as you go
into shoulder
area is not arbitrary
the hand is not lifting
the elbow is pushing
hand lifting
elbow pushing
they do different things to his arm this
just lifts his arms straight up
we'll hold this moment and you're going
to see what i'm going to do with the
shape of the hand on the wrist starting
to get his elbow to go up do you see his
elbow here's where you get greedy and
you start pushing here
keep turning the wrist
that is where the cocky projection is
right here
see
so his energy is coming in
boom
hits that
when you go like this
that's why you go around
or you get up to here
that's why you muscle this elbow
you want to make his elbow go up
we watch his elbow
just like this
elbow up
right
watch out
you see
he's now in a yin phase
now i can enter